a very warm welcome to all viewers
and in this video we will be looking at
the robotic process automation example
let us consider a discussion
between john and jamie john is very
curious and wants to know
how and where rpa is used in different
fields
jaime being a developer helps john in
understanding the rpa examples
even if you are curious to know the
applications of rpa
then you are at the right place so let's
get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement a
customer representative must understand
and solve the customer queries carry out
the necessary actions by switching
between the various softwares and
applications and inform the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data
sometimes asking for information that
has already been requested
this tends to decrease customer
satisfaction and extends call duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing rpa solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems
the customer service representative can
launch a bot
the bot completes all actions in seconds
with the press of a button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created
a customer service representative will
fill out the necessary information
to receive the queries and what will use
that data
in multiple systems to complete the
transaction
let's look at an example consider a
scenario
where a company was providing support to
the client and the company
was supposed to handle a large number of
calls
approximately 20 000 calls per month
which required a significant amount of
time spent in the support team
because of the system's complexity an
executive's average time was about 10
minutes
the system was inefficient and slow
resulting in the poor customer service
with the rpa solution the organization
gained a virtual team
that can complete the task in less than
a minute resulting in a drastic
reduction
in an execution time the rpa board
performs the following task
loading a comprehensive customer profile
obtaining a detailed billing information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated
resolving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
financial service
financial service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments
and storing the records in a system data
is manually extracted from a bank
statements
to reconcile documents and link them to
its forms using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
excel legacy software
and manual labor which is tedious and
time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds
prompting clients to pay more quickly
rpa in financial services
tracks and standardizes and validates
payments
process orders and avoids errors and is
always on top of things
such a disciplined assistant makes the
customers experience
less stressful adding value to the
service provider
rpa in finance eliminates the need for
endless email correspondence
and ensures a smooth payment approval
process matches invoices
to responsible parties and sets deadline
reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process and relieves human employees of
huge tasks
this enables precise and structured
invoice processing
consider a financial service company
that's having difficulty
extracting data from financial documents
efficiently
and accurately in order to generate
ratings
using rpa company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data
this enable decline to quickly and cost
effectively automate
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
financial service are
investment management reconciliation of
bank statements
organizing the finances record of
accounts receivables and pay
the third example is hr service this
operation
includes numerous routine steps such as
interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding
airing and firing place a significant
burden on hr and other support functions
such as i.t
security and facilities management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution
that encompasses all of these functions
and completes the necessary task for
new or departing employees some
employees can be sloppy with recording
absences vacation or in general using
the existing absence management system
so the possible solution for this is rpa
can be used to collect and screen
resumes
and online application forms contact
through background checks and compare
the information
to all the relevant job requisitions
this allows the best candidates to be
shortlisted
rpa can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees
that are both personalized and accurate
can also validate records
by cross-checking data such as absentees
reports
against time logged in the corporate
network and alerting when information is
missing or inconsistent
talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees previously the
onboarding paperwork was completed
manually
by one person consuming a significant
amount of employees time
that could have been spent on more
valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day
the company understands that an hr
department wants to provide a digital
and straightforward experience the task
required a lot of copy and paste
activities
with the implementation of rpa the bot
completed the onboarding paperwork in
less time
allowing hrs to spend more time on
corporate social responsibilities
hiring talent initiatives and improving
a company's reputation
the tasks performed by rpa bots in hr
service are
screening resumes onboarding of new
hires
attendance management induction and
training
employment management and survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
service delivery
thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication
companies looking to improve their
customer service high reliability and
accuracy of process outcomes are
required
solution the use of robotic process
automation
in telecom reduces error rates to close
to zero
improves data quality improves customer
service
and increases operational efficiency all
while contributing significantly to cost
reduction
rpa technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees
based on the employee's action a
well-structured workflow can be
generated
which serves as the foundation for
automated process by mapping each
process step with its significant cost
for manual execution
it is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and media company
decided to automate its order creation
and service removal process
to cut costs associated with the company
speed booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of rpa it
becomes simple to automate the order
build process and service removal
activity
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
telecom service are
it checks on the credit and sim card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints
porting customer phone numbers
responding to questions
from partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
healthcare systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks
that involve significant resource
allocation such as claim management
this results in high operational cost
and slow process
every industry has inefficiencies but
few face the healthcare industry's
challenges strict regulations
regarding patient data and lack of
resources to deal with
such rules building takes time after a
health care service is provided due to
manual and repetitive task in the
management process
management process include document and
data input
processing and evaluation in addition to
the automating time consuming task
patients can schedule appointments
without the intervention of hospital
employees
credit to rpa technology along with
eliminating the need of resource
allocation for scheduling
by allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly
this application can improve customer
relations rpa allows healthcare
providers to track and document each
process step
in structured log files to comply with
external audits
rpa improves data confidentiality
because bots handle this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization
deals with the process of patient
transaction data
customer details recording claims to the
process
and data reconciliation for health care
schemes are some of the manual process
they must streamline daily
the primary goal was to increase the
efficiency of existing approaches
to achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented and the most significant
possible impact was obtained
rpa platform handled claims processing
and health data reconciliation program
healthcare was able to reduce turnout on
time with this solution
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
healthcare service are
appointment scheduling regulatory
compliance
data entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment
i hope you must have understood the
examples this indeed
thank you for such a good explanation so
with that we have reached the end of
this video
like and share
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here